vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui vous avez déjà
un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel bien qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec écoute le plus de baladou
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus le si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr venu au
sans filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités data ccph
quentin avec moi de me planter plus
difficile d'être synchro 4 août et en
confinement
yes fait que dans le fond si ça donne ou
lors du septième aujourd'hui le podcast
et commencer par hangar 29 29 une
boutique de danse plus de cinquante
boutiques à travers le québec au nouveau
brunswick leur siège social est basé à
rimouski
je tenais en boutique avec les autres
les rencontrer ils ont été tellement
gentils ils ont offert du super bowl
anges dont 7 best dont c'est jean
philippe ce projet là aussi télé bell
jeans polos et jeans toi aussi du beau
linge super bon c'est sa clientèle
malheureusement là on le sait honda
confinement on peut pas se déplacer en
boutique mais ils ont une histoire
plateforme en ligne pour en ligne
vos vêtements aller voir ce qu'ils ont
subies par hbos stocks et on a un code
promo pour vous qui s'appelle sf 15 là
vous allez rentrer csf 15 dans la
plateforme dans la barre 15 % de rabais
là dessus alors je vous encourage
fortement à tes questions belle
entreprise qui l écosse est important
d'encourager aussi dans ces moments plus
difficiles
plutôt que d'acheter à des
multinationales américaines ou autres
alors encore 29 chez qui ça y est sinon
le podcast est aussi présentée par vegan
maipo plate mon entreprise on fait
livrer en ce moment des mets surgelés à
domicile donc on a réussi à mettre en
place un système de livraison qui vous
amène ce chez vous c'est des blocs sont
100% vegan sont vraiment bons pour vrai
c'est de la bombe c'est meilleur que
n'importe quel plat surgelé que j'ai
mangé évidemment cela dire que je prêche
au que je prêche pour ma paroisse mais
c'est écoutez c'est la règle du jeu
on offre dans le fond 25 % des profits
de toutes ces produits là s'en vont on
va acheter des plots professionnels de
la santé qui en ce moment sont en train
de se battre sur les lignes de front
donc on va porter sur cette semaine
c'était au chum on va on veut trouver un
autre hôpital pour la semaine prochaine
à l'elysée d un petit peu alléger leur
fardeau parce qu'on sait que c'est une
bataille extrêmement importante qui mène
pour nous puis on sait aussi que c'est
des conditions vraiment difficiles avec
lequel on a géré en ce moment donc
bnpp points c'est à triple double 20
points bnpp point ca pour commander vos
bottes
puis c'est ça y'a pas
il ya autre chose à dire là dessus on
est vraiment content de la réception de
tupi les gens aiment nos clubs puis
c'est pour une bonne cause dont khalid
sheikh et ceux ci nomme cette semaine
notre invité
sinon juste pour mentionner le le site
web pour hangar 29 encore trait d'union
29.6 à la presse avoir les miens aussi
instagram 29 pour les suivre alors félix
c'est vraiment un honneur de recevoir ce
goal
qui est un des meilleurs joueurs de
tennis au monde des rallyes simplement
comme ceux ici présents mentalement au
monde qui dieu la situation en ce moment
la saison de tennis est sur pause les
tournois qui seront apportées soit
annulée lui qui avait vraiment un bon
début de saison ce moment ça va très
bien pour lui mais ça aurait de tous
bien que tout va reprendre alors un gars
tellement premièrement généreux un très
bon comme 14 grammes en surprenant il
c'est un groupe qui partage sa passion
pit sa vision du port et la vie du
monarque leur espace pas facile c'était
vraiment un charme devants par quatre
avec lui qu'il sert à respirer parler
avec quelqu'un qui qui aussi dédié à son
sport à ce qu'il fait aussi passionnés
qui ont une approche aussi très humble
en même temps là dedans puis que
vraiment une bonne vision de de toujours
vouloir s'améliorer de chômeurs en plus
sur une bonne attitude d'athlètes
totalement 1 go conversation j'espère
que oui on a aussi soufflé plus de
contenu on a aussi une page pétrole ou
est-ce que chez qu'en ce moment la
plupart des gens sont à la recherche de
contenus sur internet parce que parce
que pas grand chose à faire donc on une
page pétrole parce qu'on fait des
podcasts juste deux mémoires puis ou
est-ce qu'on mette tous nos podcasts les
stocks sont tournés en fait l'instrument
c'est ce qu'on tourne on essaie
d'enregistrer toujours la veille la date
de diffusion pour rester à l'affût de
l'actualité mais habituellement on met
toutes les podcasts losc sont tournés
donc allé voir ce la perpétuelle nasa va
être dans la description du podcast qui
vont toutes les informations qu'ils
allaient signer des commentaires
participer diction dites nous ce que
vous pensez
notre conversation avec félix on a
vraiment apprécié sa c1
un gars extrêmement généreux de son
temps puis on espère que vous allez
avoir apprécié autant que l'autre fait
que sans plus attendre
bompas thiès bonne écoute chanteur
quinconces et parlé c'était aux gémeaux
oui c'est vrai ouaip été tête était pas
mal les lâches ou pastore on n'a pas eu
le temps de comprendre la teinte
phalempin de caste et surtout à montréal
où elle ça ça donne bien le ton
comment quand ça vaudra fait là parce
que les tout prochains tournois
centaines de livres d'avant j'étais nul
et jusqu'au 13 juillet jusqu'à présent
c'est ce que beaucoup de rumeurs que ça
va être encore plus longue des tournois
étaient présents sur le tournoi
la coupe rogers qui à toronto pour les
hommes cette année comme le seau plein à
new york au ski en ce moment il ya
vraiment des délits les lits d'hôpitaux
dans les stades de tennis c'est quand
même problématique puis peu de chances
qu'on puisse jouer cet été en amérique
après faut voir comment les choses
évoluent dans le reste du monde c'est en
europe sommet nous on est après un stand
by jusqu'à temps que tous améliorés
comme tout le monde mais est ce parce
que tout le monde doit voyager comme ça
à l'extérieur du pays chacun chacune son
pays avant qu'un vaccin et avec les
frontières soient réouvertes on n'est
pas près de bouger chez moi je suis je
suis en attente qui est je me tiens tu
payes est ce que f 4k date a entraîné un
petit peu enfin la maison je peux sortir
dans l amour qu un petit sortir courir
dans maintenant mes distances mais si je
veux pas trop loin et puis mais je fais
comme je peux à la maison si j'ai avec
mon préparateur physique on a mis une
structure en place on a pris du matériel
à la maison je suis donc la chance de
dire qu un entraînement à la maison le
spectacle quand même une bonne partie
des journées donc pas trop trop pour
l'instant parce que non je peux pas
parce qu'elle est belle au stade où
google pour moi en fait ces logements en
plein coeur chevrier complètement fermée
donc non je peux pas trop votre tapis
n'est ce pas une urgence non plus parce
que façon j'aurais pas la compétition
avant la fin de l'été ou au mieux des
mois entiers nous mettons un ouf de la
natation de compétition avant puis c'est
la natation c'est vraiment un sport de
sensations plus j'ai l'impression que le
tennis c'est vraiment semblable sur ce
point de vue le quand et à l'extérieur
du court tu pendant un certain temps
j'imagine que c'est celle ont retrouvé
des sensations le petit héros peur c'est
sûr qu'avec avec l'expérience avec les
années doit plus de repères laissant ce
soir vous revenez un peu plus vite mais
moi c'est vrai que ça peut prendre
quelques journées
comment d'entraînement complète pour
vraiment ressentir laissant les mêmes
sensations que j'avais avant là avant la
pause soit avant de m'arrêter
puis à chaque fois que c'est ça je vous
remettrons conçu une saison qu'on va en
vacances puis on fait autre chose
d'accord vient et ça prend quelques
jours qui ce soit pour les sensations
même impôt les articulations ouvert ses
portes que tu es donc ôter poignée
retrouve les mouvements qui sont en
particulier au tennis et que tu fais pas
nulle part ailleurs
ça prend quelques jours donc sauf une
petite adaptation à rome mais comme ça
comment tous les sports il ya comment
agir des sensations au filet et
reprendre à chaque fois est ce que tu
penses que l'ailé en fait est-ce que
tout est au courant mais j'imagine qu'il
ya certains joueurs qui doivent avoir
1 co est intérieur chez eux qui doivent
pouvoir continuer à travailler là dessus
ouais c'est sûr que on n'a pas tous les
mêmes revenus
c'est bien beau les revenus c'est les
mêmes installations ou et c'est les
mêmes conditions trickett
c'est un entraîneur qui était aux états
unis en floride ou même en europe ils
peuvent déjà jouer dehors et mettions
des cours privés chez eux même si
quelqu'un qui connaisse
puis je sais pas moi les joueurs
australiens c'est quoi leur situation
dit
donc chacun ramassé sur sont
particulièrement et où il est
présentement tu fais plus que tu peux
avec eux avec ce qui est autour de toi
mais ce qu'on n'est pas tous quand tous
les mêmes conditions que je me dis c'est
ce que sur une longue période c'est sur
un mois ça fait pas tant de différences
que si on s'arrête 4 5 mois puis qu'il
ya un qui continue à jouer pendant ce
temps là s'est arrêtée à la compétition
est ce qu est ce que toi tu avais
regardées de contempler avec ton équipe
peut-être l'idée de rester à quai par
ailleurs qu'au québec où cité on revient
ici puis on regarde ce qui se passe et
ce qui s'est passé en fait c'est fou
parce que c'est un peu comme tu me
disais c'est un peu irréel parce que
tout s'est passé tellement vite
moi j'étais à indian wells en californie
je me préparais pour toi là-bas qu'un
soit quelques jours en tournoi ils nous
disent que le ton est en lui parce qu'il
est un code 1 dans la région d'arlon et
comme ok mais on avait le droit ni à
millas deux semaines après quand tu vas
rester indian wells j'avais loué une
maison avec mon équipe et on était
restés un peu on va s'entraîner obstiné
de près j si la nuit a mis bon on va
voir ce qu'on fait puis sinon on va
jouer miami le quelques jours après jan
mayen miami et ensuite tout s'est
enchaîné vraiment rapidement tiré d'une
famille annuler la saison à tout parce
que tout le printemps
je me suis dit qu'est ce que je fais
j'ai ma copine que de la famille en
floride j'ai passé quelques jours là bas
parce que j'étais déjà près de miami là
parce que je me suis dit
la situation s'aggrave de jour en jour
j'aime ma famille qui était à montréal
qui m'ont suggéré tu es rentré en très
près de vos proches sur en transmet donc
le joystick et je rentre au plus vite
fait que je rentre à montréal puis deux
puis c'est ce que j'essaie de suivre la
situation de près voir ce que je peux
faire mais parce que j'étais nul aux
etats-unis on s'est dit bon on va
rentrer à montréal j'ai les entraîneurs
qui habite heures il suffit donc il aime
ça c'était la dernière option avec la
situation actuelle interafricain
finalement je rentrais c'est quand je
suis rentré j'ai fait mes deux semaines
de 10 kg d'isolement à la maison
le shit sortie la semaine de la fin de
semaine d'ailleurs quand même vendredi
dernier qui rentrait début début mars le
cas quand c'est l'événement c'est aussi
deux semaines et demie chaque sens bien
un pilote qui toi toi le moral comment
ça commence à vos invités
est-ce que ça doit être vraiment un gros
coup à prendre tout cas d'alain comme le
vent dans les voiles en ce moment ouais
j'avais connu un bon début de saison
j'aimerais voir mais non la mort à
savoir si je suis toujours dans une
chose me suit le jeune fille décide
tirer le meilleur de chaque situation
s'il voit on le sait sur ses disques
pour le côté positif mais décide
toujours faire du mieux avec la
situation actuelle donc j'ai mes
routines chaque jour et je m'entraîne
autrement si je j'ai ma lecture j'aime y
jouer les pasteurs donc je pense qu
enfin meetic
moi je passe tous les mois sur l'année
avec mon équipe
des fois seul il de rentrer en ça
m'évite d'avoir des longues discussions
en famille si des choses que je n'aurais
pas eu depuis longtemps plaisir de
s'asseoir à table et justice dépendante
de trois heures c'est des choses qui
font penser à jouer mon jeu c'est vrai
que le moral il restait quelques
secondes pour autant est ce que c'est
j'imagine que c'est très solitaire une
vie sur le pro tour c'est surtout d'un
mixte aux sports individuels peu comme
la natation ou est ce que tout le monde
à la compression alimentaire écrit
libération et à la fin de la journée
votre petit bâton amis pour pour passer
au prochain taux qui fait remonter c'est
très compétitif puis pas trop des clips
donc donc de ce côté là c'est sur le tas
mais de l'autre côté on est quand même
entourée de de nos entraîneurs des fois
non plus les deux entraîneurs qui font
chacune moitié de l'année je m'emploie
préparateur physique je fais quelques
semaines d'une fusion qui fait quelques
semaines avec moi aussi donc ça reste
que c'est quand même si je suis sur le
terrain il ya quand même une équipe de 4
personnes aussi d'ailleurs
donc malgré tout il ya quand même un
comme un bon esprit d'équipé peur dans
cette ville up si c'est rare que je
passe des moments totalement seul j'ai
toujours au moins un entraîneur avec moi
qui avec qui je partage des points
ça reste que je suis sur la bonne
relation extraprofessionnelle avec eux
que j'arrive à passer des bons moments
des bons sujets à des bonnes suggestions
à l'extérieur et aussi est-ce que tu
accordes s culture basée à monaco
ouais ouais c'est vrai j'ai fait ça fait
un an et quelques mois je suis là bas ce
qui est très pratique parce que je passe
plus la moitié de l'année sur des
tournées en europe
le temps sera venu de l'australie je
suis rentré là bas j'avais les tournois
un sud de la france hier à rotterdam
puis après je suis passé du côté des
états unis
je vais y retourner bientôt parce qu'il
y avait des tournois justement il y
avait un très gros à monte carlo puis
après tu repars tournoi donc non ça se
passe bien le move depuis
et puis depuis un an ça se passe bien
c'est quoi la toile est ce qu'une
mauvaise idée c'est quoi la différence
majeure entre la façon le vraiment au
niveau de l'entraînement le poney
serment au niveau socio économique de
monaco le sont aussi de quoi s'alarmer
au niveau de ton entraînement qu est-ce
qui est la différence majeure entre à
être là bas voir focus complètement sur
ce puits puis à être ici maintenant
quand tu t'entraînes jeu il y avait les
conditions climatiques
c'est à dire que j'ai passé tout le
monde parme à m'entraîner là bas c'était
ce degré au plus froid se saouler soi
car cela
le froid et savez ce que je peux
m'entraîner toute l'année doit très
bonnes conditions climatiques
il peut presque jamais pire les
partenaires d'entraînement aussi
beaucoup de joueurs un top 20 mondial en
top 10 mondial qui sont la porte donc à
montréal cgt beaucoup de partenaires
d'entraînement il ya des jeunes
internationale qui je vais très bien
mais ça reste que en étant monaco je
suis prêt de deux académies en france
tout ce qui est beaucoup de joueurs tout
le monde y ait beaucoup de très bons
joueurs qui réside là donc on s'entraîne
un peu entre nous puis ça fait que je
m'entraîne avec des joueurs des
champions grand chelem qui déchoit dans
le top 10 dans top 5
donc ça c'est sur cette chose là ça fait
une grosse différence il y apprit à la
tranquillité aussi de dire que tu es là
tu t'entraînes tu es comme tu veux
continuer ici c'est pour moi quand je
vais la partie des fonds parce que ce
qu'on pense à monaco si on pense au
casino pense aux parts et on pensait à
l'autre festival de cannes mais moi
quand je suis là bosch vraiment un focus
comme chez moi je crois mon entraînement
je reviens chez moi je mange et je suis
vraiment c'est vraiment juste dans un
faux que se tenait ce entraînement donc
pour ça c'est très c'est très tranquille
pour ce il doit avoir c'est rapidement
quand atteint un niveau comme comme
celui que tu as atteint et il ya des
gros des gros chèques qui commencent à
rentrer éventuellement pis ce que tu
viennes dire là de dire quand je suis
leur jeu focus à l'entraînement
j'imagine que c'est vraiment pas le cas
pour tout le monde parce qu'il s'est
souvent voix mettons un jeune qui arrive
qui aussitôt arrivé aussitôt reparti ici
parce que parce que j'imagine que ça
demande une une rigueur
incroyable tir on entend souvent les
histoires de rafael nadal puis de ces
histoires d'entraînement de commencer
c'est un gars qui s'entraînent
incroyablement fort tout le temps tu
puisses qui explique en partie son son
succès sur une d'aussi jeunes a
maintenant fait que c'est sûr que
j'imagine qu'il y en a qui doivent se
perdre la place d'astarac facile en fait
le logiciel est un expert du les
exemples qui me viennent il y en a qui
se perdent 1 que ce départ pour moi déjà
c'est ça dépend de ton objectif à la
botte
c est ce que tu veux pourquoi tu fais ce
que tu le fais pour cent des gros
chèques
il y en a qui gagnent quelques millions
qui après son sont cools avec soyons ils
font de l'argent pis at it
mais quand on objectif c'est d'être le
meilleur joueur de tennis que tu payes
tu dans ta carrière
c'est de maximiser ton potentiel c'est
de gagner les plus grands tournois qui
existe et je peux pas te permettre de te
situes faite sur les résultats vont
montrer directement tu peux pas te
permettre dans mon corps ne peut
permettre de perdre un tel depuis deux 2
de commencer à faire des des mauvais
choix de commencer à oublier qui je suis
qu'est ce que je veux faire
donc pour moi c'est très important des
jeunes de garder les bonnes personnes
autour de moi qu'ils vont garder sur le
droit chemin et après j'ai quand même
une discipline personnelle puis un
dévouement à ce que je fais qui gêne la
terre pour moi parce que je sais où je
veux aller je sais que je faire promener
c'est pour laisser emporter par des
choses qui colle pas avec avec mon
objectif donc moi je suis dit ok c'est à
chaque jour j'ai une chance de faire
quelque chose dans la bonne direction
c'est comme la d'alors et je m'entraîne
je me rapproche son livre que le veuille
ou non je me rapproche de mon objectif
la meilleure dans une phase de ma
personnalité de mon jeu donc chaque jour
6 une bonne chance de la bonne direction
donc j'essaie de maximiser ce qui
transparaît je trouve si j'obtiens que
d'entrevues de toi
vale podcast buanderie que c'est
vraiment un des capacités avoir chacun
est abject et des obstacles comme une
opportunité à apprendre qu'à devenir
meilleur chaque défaite où chacun cisco
qui revenait je trouvais quand je
t'écoute et c'est comme qui est ce
passage des perdus aux questions noah le
je me serais au final je n'ai pas gagné
mais c'est pas grave parce que je veux
apprendre de type 2 prochaine fois je
vais avoir je vais avoir amélioré dans
la flotte ses pieds ok tel match et mon
service et je trouve qu'il dépend une
pointe d'être suite je vais aller
travailler sur ces paquets mais seppi
c'est là c'est ce qui fait qu'on arrête
jamais de samedi a réagi manal d'être
nommé nadal tel tout à l'heure c'était
un des meilleurs exemples de suite
malgré tout le temps popularité tout le
film tout l'argent qui a fait le jeu est
toujours aussi passionné que son groupe
toujours aussi passionné par ce sujet
cinquième ce qui fait c'est plus loin
que l'argent soit plus loin que
n'importe quoi c'est beaucoup plus fort
je suis toujours dans l'idée de
s'améliorer peu importe comment les
gagner mieux ce qui est qui et ce qui
est beau du suspense qui a pas de
liberté qui m'aiment pas n'importe quoi
a fait le tri dans le monde des affaires
est aussi de les libérer tous les
monuments il n'y a pas de lire et
d'entendre je peux toujours même quand
ils ont prouvé qu'il était numéro un
mondial mais il continue à s'améliorer
pour rester au top donc des moyens et
qui au niveau je suis encore plein de
choses que je peux faire que je peux
mieux faire
c'était quand même une bonne nouvelle
c'est ce que je suis aujourd'hui mais je
sens auch à la limite je chante pas que
je suis limité elles changent encore
même chose que je peux mieux faire
quelque chose que je peux apprendre puis
chaque défaite comme te dit c'est
vraiment une belle opportunité
d'apprendre de voir ce que tu peux mieux
faire
puis non je pense que ceci si la
philosophie que je vais adopter le plus
souvent qui est un gros truc si qui je
pense qu'il apporte à ces outils la
résilience dans n'importe quoi la
résilience est capable de rebondir dans
n'importe quel milieu tu vas vivre des
moments difficiles des défaites des
échecs mais c'était avant de reposer
une fois plus que le ton adversaire ou
ta compétition mais soulage sur la
longueur ça fait ce fc sochaux pointe et
ça c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un bon
point puis j'ai l'impression que ça
transcende comme tu l'a bien dit ça
transforme vraiment le sport si ça va ça
va au delà vraiment de tout ceci autant
dans tu parlais de ces en a fait autant
dans une carrière professionnelle y ou
routier dans une relation mais dans une
relation se soit amical que ce soit
amoureuse ce soit avec avec la famille
va toujours avoir des obstacles
évidemment puisque ce qui forge
tu parlais de ses atouts niveau il ya
encore plein de choses que tu peux
améliorer
moi quand je nageais que je t'ai aimé
ton à mon plein potentiel je vais
peut-être dans mes disciplines mais ton
top 100 au monde dans la discipline que
je faisais puis la différence entre le
top 100 puis le top 50 était
incroyablement énorme et pas aux yeux
d'un d'un public non averti qui regarde
son sens en temps ça reste quelques
secondes pour moi c'était énorme puis
après c'était la différence en top 50
pis top 10 perdre toute la différence
entre top 10 top 2 qui est encore corps
et non à des années lumières et
scootéristes ont pu se voit là c'est
vraiment ça puis quand tu dis défaut aux
yeux du public ou exemple quelqu'un qui
s'y connaît pas trop il va voir à trois
voire deux gars taper la balle ou deux
joueurs match qui est il moi je joue et
je suis inquiet mais je rigole centièmes
durant le match fédérer s'est accroché
et que ce sera une journée
je veux gagner plus facilement mais tout
le monde tout le monde se fera pas tout
le monde sait lui servir tous ses
propres avoirs ça joue vraiment sur tous
les détails ça joue sur toute une saison
au city stade est que sur un match on
peut perdre quand un gars qui est moins
bien classée que toi parce que votre
niveau et pas si loin mais c'est
apprécié celui qui va être capable de
tout après un tournoi
la constance du niveau de l'effort de
l'implication sûr ça fait une grosse
différence qui sait ce que les maires
ont fait 16 équipes au classement
basée sur la constance et sur 56 sur 52
semaines
le classement est fait donc les joueurs
l'intégrale de d'avoir la meilleure
moyenne tout au courant de l'année et
ben ils vont être au top qui est je suis
20e jeudi 20e cinquième c'est juste
quinze places mais chaque place est
énorme a gagné t&t norma dernier puis
même
je prends un exemple comme djokovic
ménages je pense qu'ils deviennent les
banques étaient qui est devenu le tennis
pendant pendant plusieurs années qu'il
domine toujours lui pendant quand il
monte est troisième à chaque année à
chaque année finissait 3e para comme
troy cate année depuis nadal ferrer
était promis ils se partageaient la 1ère
2ème place et titille le coeur il
connaît presque tous les tournois mais
ils perdent en finale contre eux c'est
dit la marche et les efforts que disent
faire passer un jour premier son
monumental donc plus plus tu arrives en
haut de la montagne peluche a placé et
durera aggravèrent donc c'est vrai que
les améliorations c'est sur des trucs
mince mais c'est aussi sur une longue
période qui est il faut faire les
efforts petit à petit tu t'améliores
donc aurait dû passer maintenant l'été
20e au monde en ce moment est ce qu'ils
veulent à un angle deux ans dames et on
le plante était monté de tes objectifs
restent pas ses attentes ou si on le
pousse rapidement eu non plus aussi
rapidement
si je me ramène en fait j'ai connu une
très bonne année 2010 maintenant d'infos
2010 est très bonne année parce que
j'étais jeune j'avais cela les met 17
ans puis j'ai fini l'année 160e au
gaumont qui avait juste exemple nadal
lettonie woods qui avait fait ça dans
et 20 dans les vingt dernières années
donc j'étais très bien placé était
possible de mes 18 et j'ai fini juste un
dessert du top 100 j'ai pensé comme de
160 à 110 hoekstra un peu déçu autant
j'ai fait du progrès je sentais le jouer
beaucoup mieux mon classement retraités
mais je respirais de rentrer dans le top
100 parce que pour nous ce que ça veut
dire quand j'étais entraîneur ça c'était
dans le tableau principal de tous les
grand chelem durant l'année avec déjà au
niveau monétaire c'est très important
puis ça t'enlève de à chaque fois je
vois te qualifier pour ce tournoi là
c'était cette donne un accès jeff carter
ça c'est quand même un gros pour un jour
et tennis et je suis né juste d'or il
après sa saison est un peu déçu et là je
commence l'année 2019 je me dis ok si je
finis top 50 ce serait très bien je suis
dit l'année 21e en étant en ayant un
meilleur classement tu vas en est à dix
septième rexel est vraiment l'année 2009
j'ai excédé largement mes attentes
donc c'est sûr que j'ai fait un travail
pour tous s'est passé étape par étape
mais tout s'est vraiment comme pensée
dans l'idéal que je voulais même plus je
pensais vraiment sur l'année dernière
2009 parce que je me suis le plus
surpris
depuis début de ma jeune carrière est-ce
que juste pour revenir un petit peu
avant s qui est ce que il ya un moment
un match qui est arrivé ou est ce kit ou
est ce que tu te poses 510 a frappé un
mur ouest fait aux quilles
il ya vraiment un haut niveau assure le
tipi un niveau que je veux je veux
atteindre mais comme que encore une fois
pour nous qui regardent c'est comme un
crime félix et titille dans les échanges
depuis que toi toi dans ta tête tout le
monde et comme ice t vraiment un match
série pts à taxer comme non pas celle de
santé
jacques raynaud rien [ __ ] j'ai
commencé à toucher fait première finale
en février
avant ça j'ai fait une demi-finale à
miami l'a jeté comme un top 30
presque puis je suis en baisse ou les
tournois en europe en terre battue sur
terre battue qui toi ce que tu
t'entraînes tu as voici trois prêtres
est-ce que yeux de la terre battue le
faire accepter de nouveaux pour toi le
cpo comme nom du même camp ce kit alessi
qui s'ils ont bien la fédération
investis pour mettre des terrains en
terre battue au stade iga sont arrivés
environ tête je pense peut-être en 2013
et que aux décos chariots sont à
signaler le tabac tue donc c'était très
bien pour notre formation si nous
mourrons enfants jouaient à ces lamotte
ilan à l'intérieur à l'extérieur puisque
sur surface dure
les européens avaient la chance de jouer
plus sur terre battue mais et ont fait
cet investissement là ça me donner la
chance de s'entraîner ce temps là dessus
ça propose avec le ca cette surface là
parfois même en arrive à mes premiers
première belle victoire était surtout là
dessus donc c'est une surface que que
j'aime bien pis c'était comme les roms
roumains canadien de bien jouer sur
terre battue
c'était un peu nouveau mais je dirais
que l'année dernière quand je termine
sur ces tournois là je battais des
joueurs comme un temps 35 ans et après
si j'arrivais à temps jouer un match
trois tournois de suite j'ai joué du top
10 puis j'ai perdu concepteurs comptent
les tops et gibert du compte quand je
verrai si je pense que nadal
non je suis moi je pense qu'on y figurer
lorsque je pense qu'on la laisse
vraiment sentir qui se dégage des
guerrières grand chelem le de bajaur
je laisse ça aux petits légumes sont
depuis quelques années dans top 10
le gie sortie avait il ya vraiment un
step il ya une étape qui est là qui est
à franchir puis je pense qu'on l'a
refranchi encore mais je me rapproche de
plus en plus mais là j'ai vraiment senti
une différence de niveau
si j'ai perdu qu on a dit ok le score
dit que c'était accroché parce que
maintenant j'ai bien servi
mais moi je sais qu'au fond j'ai pas eu
trop de chance de le gagner puis paraît
que boiron nishikori
donc c'était vraiment des bonnes leçons
pich
je suis ressorti de ces machins comme
déçu de map un peu oui je dis ok par un
idéal j'aurais pu faire mieux je me suis
fait que manquer puis j'ai fait une
telle chose depuis le début d'année et
la réalité ce que ça prend du temps à
revendre l'offre où j'accepte le niveau
que ses galons faut que je travaille
plus fort différent de la piété se sait
c'est la prochaine étape maintenant que
je me mette au boulot pour arriver à
accrocher regardez justement le 10 le
top 100
et puis en skoda dans l'état pour moins
30 40
je pense que tu étais le seul dont large
commencer par un lutin à 100 questions
sont dans la vingtaine ou la trentaine
mais j'imagine qu'un thriller garde sous
cet angle là ça va quand même
encourageant de letat encore d'apprendre
à consommer mieux répit n'empêche qu'au
rythme auquel tout ça évolue puis auquel
tu est rapidement devenu le si je sens
courage pour la suite c'est que la
sécurité se font jusqu'à sur un avantage
pour moi c'est chez tt le temps joue
pour moi et j'ai fait de bonnes choses
déjà si je continue sur ma progression
le temps au jeu pour moi par contre le
danger ça s'est un peu de se relâcher
j'ai dit ok je tentais j'attends
beaucoup de ce genre d'erreurs mais
c'est correct ces jeunes tout le temps
mais c'est parce qu'il faut si je pense
qu'il faut c'est compétitif qui toujours
joué s'entraîner avec une une urgence si
on re 2d comme je vais avancer mais
redresseurs il faut que la journée finie
sa sortie des rallyes ce que quand j'ai
le temps le tâche pour moi je continue à
bien travailler mais ce que j'aime pas
des fois de cette pensée leur cdd comme
un même si je fais les choses
moins bien aussi je m'entraîne pas
correctement ou si je fais pas les
bonnes choses m j'aurais pu me rattraper
je le vois
voire comme je continue à bien
travailler puis le temps joue pour moi à
la fin tu veux pas tomber dans le spa
grave si j'ai perdu ce match là parce
que j'ai juste 19 ans et plus positive
et il faut pas que ce soit quelque chose
qui te moi il m'est arrivé quelque chose
quand j'avais quand je venais d'avoir 17
ans parce que la natation il
les groupes d'âge ça finit à 16 ans fait
que ça arrive à 17 ans et + cats et en
plus tu compétitionne avec tout le monde
ne tire plus de milliers plus d'âge
je me rappelle à amener j'étais en
finale avec un mais bon ami bruno qui
était plus vieux que moi pas mal
vingt quatre ans de plus que moi pis on
mangeait les mêmes épreuves
et puis je me rappelle un nom est à côté
dans finale justement puis je disais
tiens j'ai quand même des 4 ans sur sur
toi encore le tir on a faisait des tanks
étaient semblables mais j'ai quand même
quatre ans sur toi tu me regardes des
bains sérieusement puis 10
rendu là on s'en fout de 17 ans ses 17
ans et plus à catégories dont nos jeunes
en ont rien à battre
puis comme de fait quatre ans plus tard
à cette épreuve l'heure exacte me suis
amélioré dans d'autres épreuves mais
c'était preuve là exactement j'ai jamais
fait plus vite que bruno t parce que
parce que je suis passé à autre chose
parce que mot tg j'ai mis mon travail à
erreurs mais parce que je peux rester
focus sur exactement ce quatre ans plus
tard mais ne jetons à la même place
c'est vrai que c'est parce que j'ai pas
mal de joueurs américains qui lui disait
que son compatriote
un des autres joueurs américains ils
étaient très bons jeunes puis après dans
les problèmes personnels puis il ya peu
stagner comme deux années ce domaine ne
supporte pas de voir des clubs plus
jeune que lui à mettre mieux classés
vous êtes sans parler payante est comme
ça m'a mené à la fin de refaire notre
carrière
on va jouer notre tennis qui a la foi et
qui a gagné plus de tournois qui tient
au fait qu'ils ont de meilleur palmarès
mais à la fin si les très médiatiques et
les gens dans les médias j'aime beaucoup
et c'est le potentiel c'est la promesse
et il pourrait faire ça à cause que tes
résultats sont morts à la fin comme sait
si bien dit c'est dans son foot et à
free de quelle gauche et gagner on est
tous dans le même scénario vraiment ce
que c'est comme ça que j'essaie
d'approcher ce que tu l'a bien dit c'est
très médiatique loges le monde est
monsieur les storylines les gens
l'aiment chaud est capable de suivre tu
la 1ère
je pense qu'il a vraiment bien exprimé
il ya une autre anecdote qui me vient en
tête je sais pas si tu écoutes un petit
peu le basket dreams and green state je
gagnais le joueur défensif de l'année
3,3 fois champion de la nba lui qu'à qui
est sortie du du collège basketball
qu'un que ces fêtes drafté il y avait 21
ans fait qui est sorti vraiment beau
dans le ranking parce que il restait
trois ans à l'université alors que les
autres restent un an puis c'est warren
buffet qui reste un hayon 18 ans ils
seront repêchés à 18 ans puis toutes les
lire
tout laisse les gens qui faisaient leur
qualité les gens qui faisaient le
repérage dans les universitaires même si
james green était meilleur que des gueux
18 ans il recrutait les gars 18 ans a
menti parce qu'il y avait la première
parce qu'il y avait là l'avenir devant
eux
puis comme de fait le temps retrouvé que
de ceux du raf claude jamin guînes est
probablement le meilleur joueur à être
sortis tout droit flop il est sorti je
pense fin première ronde ou deuxième
ronde à cause de son ordre ces fous ils
s'intéressent à ces récits très
élastique très médiatique je pense que
beaucoup pour saint ex premier est ce qu
on s est dit
cc c'est tout le monde aime ça c'est
très médiatisée c'est eux
j'aime vraiment voir en tout cas que
j'aime vraiment entendre ce que tu dis
par rapport à ça parce que ça ça permet
de rester ultra positif par rapport à
ton potentiel python futur si tu
considères des jeux sur comme étant pas
une excuse s'il est aussi le double
tranchant de céder à quel point on
dollars justement sicile nouveaux
espoirs le coma qui se sait le prochain
s'il ou acquise celle de notre prochain
puis quand je vois où le canadien ou pas
puis finalement dans l'écho où les
résultats finalement sont pas à la
hauteur de la promesse espérait lui des
fois aussi un genre de désaveu du public
envers certains athlètes qui on avait
tellement espoirs ces personnes au pif à
en bout de ligne les performances d'une
personne qui sait choix aussi ça regarde
que cette personne ait dans le sens qui
est ici on en est le meilleur exemple
chez les femmes sa vie a fait le choix
de le mans mètres du tas de l'énergie
ailleurs que dans des nestes qui dit
quoi a le droit je savais où j'allais je
m étais tout ce que je veux c'est comme
si un jour j'en sens comme un professeur
professeur métier à la fin personne pour
blesser personne et fait d'illégal ça le
juste choisi d'orienter sa carrière sur
différents aspects qui le sépare de
diana était rude parce que l de sang
prennent et ouais six ans par par joe
saward été plus heureuse au lieu de 0,6
je me dire au niveau correct en raison
trois heures je vais bien gagner ma vie
mais en plus je pourrai orienté sur
saulx d'autres choses qui vont observer
âprement intérieur ou une chose que j'ai
envie de partir mais moi je veux pas de
problèmes mais par contre moi c'est
comme si tu décides quelque chose c'est
à petit va à fond mais on sait pas ce
qu'elle a décidé donc c'est de juger les
joueurs c'est performance by gb risque
et a dit gandhi
les gens ont comme des attentes pour moi
c'est des attentes et quant aux quads
attentes et que tu es juste content
tonton toyota mais quand une attente
même si twitter est très satisfaisante
par une déception et qui aime ce qu'on
regarde sa carrière tient à le faire une
finale à wimbledon deux demi finales
dans ses autres htc de carrière
incroyable trucage plus de choix le
tennessee culte et donc se dit mais
c'est comme après c'est les attentes
c'est après riez vous régaler seriez m
simon et les attentes
je courais je peux facilement comprendre
que cette ville à des sacrifices
puis de travail constat après plusieurs
années ça se peut que ce soit juste
fatigué plus facilement contre avec eux
ses portes et pas évident s'il prend le
mans pas pour tout le monde et puis tu
le dis aussi l'après carrière c'est
camané l'espèce paradoxe que si tu veux
être le meilleur dans ce que tu fais de
qom par choix de penser juste à ceux ci
de faire que ce sauf que
tout athlète va avoir une retraite
prématurée avant tout une vie après the
aviv le tri c'est quand même quelque
chose auquel c'est normal je pense que
ça peut inquiéter ou ça peut les gens
peuvent jamais commencé à préparer cette
fête après carrière parce que sinon
c'est un méchant saut dans le vide quand
même de passer de 2 to à rien maintenant
sous tes les gens ils vont parler défaut
dès ce matin sur un filet de secours
routier de dire comme ouvert d'esprit tu
dois d'esprit d'orienter à bordeaux 12
heures d'autres d'autres d'autres
intérêts d'autres centres d'intérêts je
pense que c'est très important même si
bien le faire l'athlète est reparti
parce que tu veux juste plus complet le
serein c'est moi je suis je suis plus
sereine en ce sens que je sais qu'à la
fin je serai très bon joueur de tennis
mais j'arrive à m'intéresser à autre
chose j'avais d'autres son intérêt donc
et 800 jusqu'à une personne simple
complète et adaptée
moi tout ce que je sais faire c'est
jouer au tennis et c'est une chose qui
est importante mais je pense que tu
oublies copriété dans n'importe quel
domaine
si tu veux un paire de jeans à être
auteur le projet d'investir tout elle
vit la dinde et puis c'est ce que j'ai
fait depuis je t'en fais avec mon père
qui a commencé à m'entraîner d'après les
prochains entre artistes et c'était
vraiment delétoile puisque lui une
académie qui envoie les lieux certains
jeunes qui il faut les jeunes saisissent
pas aussi là l'investissement que ça
prend c'est ce qu'ils veulent il
n'arrête le temps mais ils se séparent
lille à l'épaississement qui s'apprend
qui s'est vraiment je te dis presque ta
vie tu iras transport intérieur qui
après trop le temps mais attend à
d'autres périodes où le seul bon exemple
des fois la vie vaut arrêter
saint-sylvère effet le temps des chemins
pense à autre chose mais quand tu es
dans l'action aux côtés d'acteurs
vraiment moi j'essaie d'investir tout ce
que je fais
que ce soit sur le terrain et hors du
terrain et ça soit dans la bonne
direction de ma carrière et ça c'est
vraiment c'est hyper important
ces délais sont qu'après avoir fait le
10 sport petit moi j'ai fait du sport à
un niveau vraiment différent de celui ph
vraiment ils m'ont élevé après ce toit
c'est encore je pense un autre games
factice et les comparer mais je pense
que vous faites du sport jeunes de façon
sérieuse et la personne de survivre si
utile la nation de vouloir à chaque
matin seule vie puisse améliorer et ce
samedi lloris avait posé les
performances améliorer sa condition
physique admirer dans le sport juste
s'améliorer points et s'assoit à prendre
mais en face c'est dans ton travail que
ce soit niveau personnel ça reste c'est
l'espèce des motards désir à devenir
meilleur à chaque jour par se transpose
à prayssas d'endoscopes c'est ce qui est
qui bossent pas jouer les leaders d'al
est ce que tu es t orienté dans la
musique ou si peu sur elle je ne veux
pas avoir l'air cool et seriez surpris
la méphédrone oui justement j'ai
carrément fait les le switch dans le
fond j'étais là disparaître le
secondaire c'était vraiment la natation
qui comme si tu joues à plus de guitare
comme comme l'oiseau je suis rentré j'ai
pas musique entre à 16 17 ans qui est
vraiment comme un switch ces faits dit
justement c'est comme si toute la
discipline qui toutes les formes et
toutes les tensions que je mettais dans
ma discipline sportive
je les réorienter dans dans la musique
vraiment servi j'ai l'impression d'avoir
cette discipline au chu je suis
convaincu que peu importe le niveau de
partir que ce matin les leçons quatre
anneaux sport compétitif c'est des
leçons que tu gardes à vue et puis c'est
mon par lui et son académie puis à la
barre les valeurs ou les leçons qu'ils
essaient tiré dix mois avec vos enfants
si je fais des champions j'essaie de
faire les championnats
leur sport dans le tennis mais aussi
dans la vie et et puis on a toujours des
exemples d des joueurs avec qui j'ai
joué comme étant enfant qui aujourd'hui
sont aux études sorties elles sont
exemple à une version mondiale au
sénégal qui on se revoit d'une audi q5
un cd des moments qui restent gravés
hadji c'est des leçons à lui dit qu'ils
vont garder en vie de ce soit à titre
contre 10 la discipline la compétition
l'engagement dans ce que tu fais ils
savent que s'ils veulent aux auteurs ils
doivent s'engager complètement dans ce
qu'ils font
donc c'est à la fin si c'est que c'est
un cadeau que nos paramètres mais
patrick est un sport un premier ticket
de m alors on se pense comme moi c'est
un cadeau parce que ça va donner des
leçons peau pour tout le reste de sa vie
qui sont qui sont vraiment importantes
comme te dis oui m un bain juste d'être
mécanisme
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un truc que
cela impose pas regarder parce que on
sent vraiment les respectables de ça
parce que vous êtes face à face pendant
dé longs matches difficiles a dit à
chaque balle l'autre ma la fin du match
y en a un qui célèbre bien un qui triste
mais on sent quand même le respect puis
la médecine m'a manqué un petit job
c'est bon je trouve
j'allais dire ça rebondit un petit peu
sur ce que doom bien dire
il ya quelque chose avec les sports
individuels puis je veux savoir qu'est
ce que tu en penses
ou est-ce que pipi c'est une leçon qui
reste mot qui m'est resté à moi jusqu'à
maintenant le tir puis c'est que s'il ya
quelque chose qui si une contre
performance ou si t'es pas le résultat
escompté de une seule personne qui est
responsable
c'est toi moi je me rappelle j'ai joué
au hockey pendant un but quand j'étais
plus jeune je faisais de la natation du
rock en même temps puis ok car on
perdait
c'était vraiment facile pour moi comme
réflexe de diriger la faute vers
quelqu'un d'autre parce que j'étais pas
d'insultés mais dans un sport individuel
4 une contre-performance quand tu perds
une course quand tu tu fais tu poses ton
temps mettons en natation aux quand tu
tu rates des coûts que j'imagine qu'elle
quitte et est habitué à prat et tu peux
pas blâmer
oui peut-être que ton programme
d'entraînement était pas optimal mais
quand tu fais une contre-performance
était la seule personne à blâmer
puis ça ça me suit jusqu'à maintenant
c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui arrive
qui va pas comme je veux
c'est ma faute
au final c'est à moi de régler le
problème ici c'est à moi de prendre en
charge tout ça c'est quelque chose que
le sport individuel mais vraiment je
coupais le plus d'accord c'est trop
j'avais cette même section avec me parle
plutôt bien que mon mon entraîneur aussi
aimer deux entraîneurs c'était la
réflexion qu'on supposait tpiy ce qui me
répétaient quelquefois si tu es
responsable de tepito a été défaite qui
à la fin quand seconde c'était c'est un
bon feeling parce que tu dis j'ai fait
des efforts j'ai gagné parce que si
c'est quand j'ai gagné c'est ma faute
c'est comme ça ma participative c'est
parti depuis la défaite appartient aussi
il doit tellement mieux apprendre qui
mousse ce qui me punit le plus simple
des fins professionnelles c'est des gens
qui vont essayer de mettre les excuses
sur les autres pilotes et qui les choses
qui se passent dans leur vie c'est
toujours de la faute d'un autre c'est
ici c'est très dur pour moi comme
concert pas copains qui eux sinon je
vais finir aussi le son que ça donne ne
se produirait de la prendre la
responsabilité sur les épaules comme why
are n'y ait plus rien plus fort il ya
mieux puis ça c'est vraiment le sujet
s'est très c'est très fort là dessus qui
n aura pas été question aussi dominique
dans le tennis j'aurai une anecdote
cette année il ya un respect mutuel
parce que tout le monde sait à quel
point c'est difficile
2011 d'un toulon
ce n'est pas le match nul aussi il ya
pas match nul et puis des fois il devra
en avoir parce que les deux joueurs il
faut combattre jusqu'à la fin il ya
juste un petit peu gagner tu peux passer
puis fois c'est très très très difficile
mais je suis pas grand-chose qui a par
exemple cette année j'étais à marseille
qui je fais finale au tournoi avec deux
premiers matches je sont pas le match de
jeudi
les deuils d'arles qui donne un point de
me battre le 7 juillet pis au deuxième
tour show balle de match je gagne le
premier set 6 0
j'explose legault premier set
complètement puis après le deuxième set
d'un petit haut record à 0
là on est accroché comme son service 6
mètres vieux savez ça fait 1 2 2 jusqu'à
6 ans à voter oui j'ai je pense que john
balle de match pour moi à 5-4 6-5 après
a sauté briques lego sur l'iph un point
incroyable effet un coup incroyable ce
n'est pas ainsi jambes et me l'ops c'est
vraiment de la folie c'est le public
était carrément fou dont qui donne ces
sept longs mois je souris comme je pense
que c'était le cas mode et moi j'ai
soulevé la marge au premier tour j'avais
ça c'est comme ça jusqu'à la fin
lala au troisième set encore un jusqu'à
ce système rich et danseurs des ballets
match soit mutuellement
puis au final effet un double faute qui
me donne pas le match que je fais mes
choix l'os je gagne le match
qui sait la côte étaient contents mais
après ça si je tarde aux fidèles
s'étaient comme jeter quand même cette
quantité désole t on la respecte et on
s'y fait tout comme assure s'est fait
tout un combat qui il tient respect pis
ce que l'on apprécié allemand hermann
grande classe et ça vu que j'aime bien
en français qui s'appelle herbert puis
un incroyable qu'après aux vestiaires
il me dit tu es vraiment un bon match
pierre getti je partais pas trop fatigué
pour la sûreté
il me dit est dit vraiment bonne chance
pour pour la supplier comme c'est pour
moi c'est le respect ultime seulement la
classe et élégant par l'un des fêtes
christian est capable de reconnaître
qu'on s'est fait respect un match
incroyable qui que ça continue puis
vraiment beaucoup de respect pour ceux à
qui je pense que c'est un expliqué à ses
cours à manhac tennis mais c'est une
belle histoire main qu'elle est là quel
est le la porte du mental dans ce match
de tennis comme celui là on
al'impression puis probablement
peut-être que ce parce qu on se le fait
martelé par un pari van rompuy qui est
quel est l'état du bon pied link et
c'est le mental c'est la chose la plus
importante c'est quoi la porte du mental
qui est ce que vraiment est ce que
vraiment il ya des moments où est ce que
ton adversaire entre dans ta tête
puis soudainement tu deviens sa défense
et ifpi tuqiri speech par ton ton jeu ou
c1 où c'est un petit peu trop exagéré
mais ton l'effet de tulle
c'est un peu exagéré je pense que tu
quand j'entends que c'est la fois
j'entendais un chiffre que c'est 90%
monteur puis que ce que tout joue sur le
mental
je n'ai pas autant oui une grosse partie
mais ça reste que celle des fois comme
s'ils vont dire est que qui domine le
circuit est devenu le circuit
parlementaire ces deux minutes je pense
que je mènerai s'appuyer avec beaucoup
d'autres choses sur certains moments ils
sont très fort mentalement ils ont très
grande résilience jeté une combativité
et pour moi combativité seulement si tu
lâches related du premier au dernier
point tu loges pour le moment du match
mais je pense que pour moi il ya des
moments où est ce que oui le mental joue
et parce que j'ai crispé parce que
j'étais nerveux mais je dirais que c'est
un peu normal parce que c'était pas
nerveuse
tout moment ce n'était pas humain et je
faisais des émotions qui viennent au
moins le gros apport menteur c'est comme
entre n'est pas de gérer ces émotions là
c'est l'axé c'est le site
il y en a qui sont beaucoup plus forts
que d'autres parce qu'on va tous se
ressentir une fois les mêmes crispation
ou la même nervosité la même rage la
même frustration mais c'est est capable
de canaliser sa est capable d'avoir une
pensée positive est temps de penser qu
est ce que je dois faire pour gagner le
prochain point être là quelque chose de
constructif
le stand vos différences et puis deux
puis j'ai commencé ces professionnels
j'essaie de le mettre en place des ces
une fois que le match était fini et on
fera le feed back après le match on va
s'asseoir mais coach est temps que le
match n'est pas fini on reste dans le
présent on pense au futur monde et on
est dans le positif
ainsi trouver un moyen de le retrouver
le chemin de la victoire
qui sait ce que j'essaie vraiment de
mettre en place c'est la partie mentale
par contre moi je trouve que la plus
grosse partie c'est les habitudes qu'ils
ont pris ces joueurs là c'est quand te
répéter un mouvement distec hobby qui
disait que lui il ya l'appétit du caire
il faut qu'ils chantent le 2 3 points à
dernière seconde pour lui c'est comme il
y en avait un ou un autre plus cités
c'est juste un an de plus je pense que
le cas de répéter un mouvement pendant
des années il commis les bonnes
habitudes
de fait le bon mouvement à chaque fois
sur six pense que c'est plus fort que le
mental parce que justement quand je mets
10 ou 20 10 et quand tu es tellement été
habitué à faire un mouvement est de
toute façon est presque parfaite ou
excellente mais pour les distractions
qui vont venir au moins certaines tombes
et ne soit pas tombé trop beauté par
contre si t'as pas répéter les bonnes
choses belles il parle beaucoup de
variations par rapport à ce que sa part
rapporté mentale et quant à la technique
est tout est solide et remplace le
mental va pas faire bouger ton résultat
beaucoup
donc moi je pense que sélection très
fort c'est qu'elle nadal djokovic ont
tellement répété bien leur mouvement à
chaque match par leur quotidien ce que
n'importe qui se passe ça bouge pas trop
d'hommes je vais faire un parallèle
petit mois ci
ça fait du sens le je m'étais déjà fait
dire que un musicien quand mettons tu
composes une toune dans le potentiel de
la jouer live
il faut que tu sois capable de la jouer
live s'y met on est à 80% des capacités
fait mes tantes et kim est honteux repas
une tournée mettons que faut que tu
fasses un instit solo de malades qui
étaient comme des limites d'être capable
de le faire quand tu es dans les
meilleures conditions précise musée je
compose reprochons pour aller le phare
live non c'est clair c'est clair
absolument sûr menti parce que c'est ce
que avec dans le moment il va arriver un
petit quelque chose qui peut dans des
conditions différentes qui est évident
que le sport c'est sûr que si tu fais se
situe compte c'est comme si ce comté car
chaque balle allait le faire le meilleur
service de ta vie tu ça sera mieux ce
sera pas le cas
non évidemment qu'ils étaient mieux de
pratiquer quelque chose pour être
vraiment à l'aise d'avoir facilement le
facilement mais aussi des capable de
faire parce qu'autant dans le sport que
dans la musique ou dans d'autres
disciplines c'est qu'il faut que moment
qu'il fasse qu'il a tellement fait que
ça soit seconde nature inconsciente de
réfléchir à la vitesse qu'ils étaient
match devant tu imagines tu as pas le
temps de réfléchir à rien c'est
l'instant on en a 25 selon un oncle et
les points que tu perds préfet sherlock
et mes tantes et à 40-30 que ce que je
veux faire sur ce point leur peau ok
c'est quoi la mer arctique
une fois que le parti sait que
l'instinct c'est comme un rêve tu vas
trouver sécurisé habitudes ont été
prises comme des débats tels que tu vois
qui joue la jouent leur jeu monte au
filet le suisse ici tout est effectif
donc que de répéter les bonnes choses
instinctivement c'est les bonnes choses
qui vont sortir faut avoir une marge
bonne marge d'erreur comme teddy qui
dans le sport aussi ce qui est beau
c'est que tu peux gagner j'avais un
appel samedi live avec charles hamelin
et on parlait de ce justement comment
sur certaines performances et pato
meilleur mais ramos elle soit gagnée
quand même si des rumeurs souvenirs
ou tu vas voir première à cuba ou 6
cents par titre
comment parler des sensations talent
n'est pas des meilleures sensations mais
je trouve le chemin de la victoire avec
d'autres moyens et quelques autres ceux
qui sont forts les toques trop au monde
sait qu'ils sont tellement au dessus
d'eux mêmes quand il descend à 70 % de
leurs capacités
il passe quand même au dessus et c'est
très très fort c'est des fois je me
rappelles tu vois je me rappelle comme
si c'était encore le mais tu vois nadal
avec des bandages par tous les genres y
enlève son tee shirt il ya les abdos
complètement strappé délégué ses pieds
sont scrap au complet mais même quand
qui est inquiet comme ça dans londres et
dans un plâtre cette imagination un plan
capable d'être de faire des demi finales
de grand chelem
c'est fou j'ai une anecdote elle a su
aussi je parle à son oncle toni
toni nadal une fois puis j'ai tout le
temps les estrades ingrat casquette lui
- il le dit - le lien prayon lyon arrêté
le lait concentré sur l'académie mais
qui me racontait qu'il est en finale je
pense qu'ils devraient juste et droit en
finale et en demi finale le match avec
un espagnol verdasco médias comme un
match de quatre heures et demie je sais
pas mais match de fou qui fait comme il
y avait une journée de break puis après
c'est le lendemain jouer la journée
drake et aimante hui rien fait le guet
presque il s'agit des traitements toute
la journée à essayer de 1 6 2 être au
mieux pour le lendemain le jour la
finale qui s'échauffait avant la finale
il dit hitachi qui dit à son nom qui tu
es
si j'ai mal à la tête j'ai mal à
l'épaule dit j'ai mal partout
il devait jouer dit j'ai mal partout les
hiriart 10 en finale de deux choix soit
du conteneur plein dictée mal partout
dit regard du christ est presque quatre
heures avant la finale histoire va faire
une sieste et elle récupère et on va
voir qui est allé gagner la finale
finalement mais c'est là que moi je
trouve que tu as ton histoire comme ceci
dit nos limites dont les connais pas tu
es gentil part je pense que tu attendais
pas
va s'arracher vraiment arriver aux
marches quitté l'adrénaline embarquée
c'est là aussi que le mental est fort
parce que limite des fonds les repose
pieds avec avec respect dans la tête et
financières a gagné le match
enfin c'est quelqu'un qui était
totalement cuite et une anecdote que je
trouve intéressant ça remet les choses
en perspective
c'est que m puis le jeu je fais un jour
faire un saut un petit peu douteuse puis
parce que parce que nadal il ya vu des
avait trempé un petit peu dans des
allégations de dopage sportif à un
moment dans sa carrière le je vais pas
te demander de tremper le moins mais
est-ce que sur le pro tour c'est quelque
chose que tu es au courant non ou c'est
quelque chose que tu as vu passer tant
attendu par les pas du tout qui même
dans le passé oui j'ai eu des histoires
mettons ainsi agassi andre agassi le
même dit dans son livre c'est que que la
tp le couvert un de ces tests nous les
autres l'histoire que j'ai vu à date de
ma carrière si cette année une journée
ma voix mondial en double qui étaient
bannis qui est un choix d'un jeune
joueur chilien aussi que je connais bien
qui bannit le joueur de double a plaidé
à sa cause jeudi qui a été non coupable
c'était comme dans la viande piquet fils
mais c'était incroyable meloni sa cause
ils ont libéré puis le libero o je suis
mais c'est pas les histoires que
j'entends trop moi si je fais confiance
au système de retenue société cassée des
cibles des jeux aussi c'est comme est
tellement tactique ça je vois des
joueurs physiquement ils sont
incroyables mais ils peuvent être deux
centièmes aux montois un petit a beau
être voir diffuser du spam le bo c'est
ça va je serai capable de courir sur
kara de courir tout les atouts
c'est toi qui va être le bad boy light
valeo a précisé la pp
moi je me dis c'est sûr que ça fait une
différence si quelqu'un est dopée mais
c'est pas le spa ou est-ce que là ça
fait une plus grosse différence
après moi je fais confiance au système
aussi à moi je suis resté n'importe
quand je ris marché je peux venir le
coach me dit desjoyeaux ont été assez
testé sur plusieurs années j'espère que
ce système est assez bon et et ce dépôt
pour pour les attraper si lille fond
mais il ya plein de rumeurs mais je sais
pas trop à marquer la danse et des joies
aussi qu'ils sont frustrés et et qui ont
perdu ou pis ils sont dix c'est ce que
je ne il ya une fois il ya un pas qui
m'a demandé ça est ce que je lui disais
je dis que je me connais je sais comme
10 à mettre qu'un jour j'arrive à face
que ils font tout va des genres est ce
que tu vas dire fixes et doper
non parce que tu me connais mais les
autres ce que tu les connais partie du
décor et pas connaître l aventure à
acheter peut être comme toi moi qui se
connaissent peas jamais histo prêter
mais attention apportée les allégations
afin de partir des rumeurs sur des gens
qui connaît vraiment pas ce que n'est
même pas ce qu'ils font changer au bout
de six mois je les fais un jour sans au
pfc quoi jaillit au risque que quelqu'un
paie déjà ah ouais mais soyez dopé et et
moi j'avais déjà entendu on pas dit que
je n'avais pas mon htc technique russie
je tenais en afrique et j'ai pas mon âge
toujours partir des conspirations des
rumeurs comme souvent je trouve c'est la
confiance qui est un sport qui qui somme
toute clean en général ouais ouais je
pense je pense on parle et je sais ça me
fait penser à sion parler de la route
alors plus juste que tu es un désir le
bloc exane et dans l'hymne national les
remparts de québec en fait dans
l'élection majeure du québec avait un
gain qui s'appelait grigorenko puis
grigorenko et exposé sortir vraiment au
dans le dans le draft
puis comme une ou deux semaines avant le
graff qui comme un article qui sort
comme de quoi grigorenko y avait trois
ans de plus qu'eux y exposer à voir si
c'est une pratique comme qui étaient
déjà arrivés pour les ruches fait que la
grille ringot et j'ai chuté dans le
classement mais le monde ils n'ont pas
de sens ce n'est pas la bonne la bonne
vieille technique du même avis aux idées
reçues c'est cet accord là j'ai peu près
même si des fois quand je pense que tu
j'ai commencé à jouer pour moi d'y
organiser trois internationaux en fait
les ratios quand même quant aux 11 12
ainsi rejeté leurs demandes en france la
première année j'avais dix ans j'ai fait
demi finale play in après j'avais 11 ans
j'avais gagné il y avait deux ans
j'avais 10 ans ils devront d'abord 11 6
2 jo du poil et toujours jeudi mauvais
genre alors si je lis revues comme 18
ans le gaillard ils ont les mêmes mots
l'été c'est que je suis et que je suis
beau position mais aussi beau moustache
à quelqu'un quand je jouais au hockey tu
sais tu arrives à un an j'ai joué
jusqu'à bantam du bantam je peux malok
que la plupart des gens ont leur poussée
de croissance mais dans chaque catégorie
d'âge tu restes le 2 fait qu'acheter ma
première année bantam paris dans une
équipe moi j'ai eu ma poussée croissance
qu'en même temps le temps
façon j'ai eu un pinch mou pendant
longtemps qu'il t'arrive le plus y'a des
gars là dedans qui ont des estives
barbieux et du poil de poche ses pelotes
prends ta douche après les game
puisqu'un baisse quant à 2 face à
douchez
les gars sont là avec leurs poils de
poche qui leur barre fixe on joue dedans
mais je voulais te parler un peu de
l'aspect professionnel ce que moi c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéresse beaucoup
au su des athlètes amateurs mais le plus
proche d'un athlète professionnel qu'on
a reçues c'est georges laraque
constatant que son son sa carrière
d'athlète professionnel dap date un
petit pull moi tu m'aurais dit mettons à
fin de ma carrière si tu m'avais dit je
te donne la chance de le compte de
continuer pour trente mille pièces mais
tonnes par année
je leur ai fait je leur ai fait jusqu'à
dire que mon corps me loge complètement
si jamais j'ai même entraîné à ce point
le que j'étais arrivé à un espèce de
croche l'aude où est ce que le step
je peux je fais plus d'argent quand ça
va te coûter de l'argent faire sur ses
pieds tu peux plus d'entraîner ckoi
mettons quinquin toi tu es arrivé à un
moment c'est quand même temps que tu
t'es dit acquis non là je suis un
athlète professionnel une fille qu'est
ce qui a changé mettons dans ta façon de
voir le sport parce que c'est sûr que
quand le sport devient ta profession
c'est sûr qu'il ya un autre c'est sûr
qu'un switch j'imagine dans la façon que
ça ça prend la place dans ta vie tu y
penses que met-on n'importe qui qui fait
qu'ils travaillent 40 heures semaine
mettons dans n'importe quel domaine
c'est sa profession il va travailler 40
heures sans fait que tu veux un peu
marre que nous nous nous nous nous
passer à travers un peu le processus de
toute la différence que ce que tu
connais bien c'est qu'ils tkt pas payer
pour tes ordres qui est en train de
s'était payé à ta performance finale que
c'est pas comme on n'est pas un autre
comme des travailleurs autonomes ou des
travailleurs la commission autres que
haman et si d'un résultat pour être
qu'au passé moi si je parle de mon
histoire personnelle
c'est une histoire particulière mais je
peux aussi nommer des exemples de joie
que je connais mais parce que moi mon
histoire
le fait que j'ai été que je certaines
performances d'une piscine recul comparé
tenter d'être jeune d'avoir certaines
performances
là par contre ça aide beaucoup parce que
le fait que j'ai été bon je ne mélange
pas remis plus jeunes comme 11 12 ans la
fédération canadienne et le corps brûlé
sur moi puis une chose c'est qu'ils
retirent jeunes qui on était 6 août et 7
garçons au sens national
quand je t'avais j'avais 14 ans ex école
des jeunes à temps il va prendre à 14 15
ans jusqu'à 18 heures puis là et gimme
gimme sur quelques jeunes il est fort
puis en fait c'est comme subventionnent
leur développement avec aussi l'aide de
tes parents mais des parents quand même
beaucoup moins payer puis après après ce
système pour redonner sur plusieurs
années c'est comme un petit fou et si tu
devrais je être visionnaire
après comme une l'ined moi j'ai des amis
à moi qui sont adam leur star américaine
qui joue tojours qui espère après lost
et intégrité circuit professionnel de
près de mon corps à moi que j'ai des
crises occupation à 17 ans et donc c'est
sûr que j'ai une chance et j'en suis
conscient que parler par les otages
avaient tous âges eu la chance d'avoir
de tenir les subventions c'est de la
fédération qui en fait j'ai signé un
compte et des contrats avec des
compagnies comme aqua une raquette
babolat ou ou avec nike qui m'ont permis
avoir des subventions nécessaires pour
payer ma carrière mais après le qatar
est aujourd'hui maintenant je suis
vraiment choix professionnels c'est là
aussi que les gens exemple ils vont voir
tes bons garder l'argent c'est parce que
quand on s'est écrit jacques son frère
dans un tournoi vous êtes quasiment
classés selon d'une dose tu es petit
gangster gens qui écoutent point fait
que c'est pas mal égal à égal
après c'était déjà un grand chelem ben
c'est beaucoup d'argent de l'enchère ça
peut changer mais déjà il ya deux choses
qui à défaut les gens il faut qu'ils
vont pas passer c'est que des jachères
tournoi avait été taxé selon la taxe
locale c'est hugo un tollé en france
ben si l'impôt ou la taxe en france et
30 %
ben tu veut taxer tout attrait pour sa
blessure puis après il ya aussi tous les
frais tuto pays c'est parce que tu as
palais sports individuels par rapport à
un sport d'équipé
les équipes qui n'ont pas pensé à payer
leur entraîneur leur stage qu'est-ce
qu'elle renvoyait à acheter
mais c'est moi quand je dois couvrir jeu
découvrir les jeux tous les frais des
voyages les hôtels le taux high tech va
mais pas pour des entraîneurs et des
fois j'ai un entraîneur un physio des
fonds et trois sur les grands chelems il
faut en mettre quatre actifs
je dois payer maintenant non mais pas
sur des lits superposés dans des
auberges et hôtels 4 et 5 étoiles c'est
elle qui après midi les tarifs pour les
joueurs il ya arrange les choses et ça
reste que ça fait beaucoup de coups à la
finale parce que payer leurs salaires
mais tu te payer l'hôtel qui leur volent
aussi donc ça ajoute t pour un joueur du
top 10 qui est une équipe complète
on peut parler de presque 500 mille
dollars à fin d'année en retrait de 2
dès qu'il est tout tout tout quelqu'un
qui sait peut-être oui je sais qu de
tout faire les réservations puis de
gérer ton argent parce que ça ça sonne
comme une distraction non j'ai un agent
jeune âge est ce que
participer lui je devrais dire je suis
pas sûr et deux assistantes où elle tout
ce qui pousse et de la logistique
parce qu'il doit la personne qui est là
ils sont ainsi tombés ce club de l'est
vraiment la logistique est tout oui on a
un bon système en place pour que ça
marche mais je sais c'est la réalité
c'est que plus on est gros mais ça coûte
aussi beaucoup mais c'est un
investissement tu fait pour ta carrière
c'est comme dire ben moi je vais avoir
je parle de fusion par travail trophies
et georges tin entraînements ça m'a
coûté beaucoup moins cher mais ce n'est
pas tout les moyens en place pour
arriver au top niveau
par contre si tu fais exemple un million
bossard fin d'année que tu dis mais je
suis prêt à mettre 500 mille dollars de
ça dans mon équipe c'est aussi une façon
de dire si j'ai investi dans mon sport
et j'investis dans ma carrière j'ai
investi pour un jour avant au niveau
depuis en fait encore plus donc c'est
une façon de voir aussi tic
moi je pense pas que tu devrais sauver
sûr si tu peux rhin a précédé une
pérennité mais quand les moyens
devraient investir dans ta carrière dans
tes entraîneurs et après les routes
euros mais mais la réalité c'est que le
tennis pas individuel on est très
chanceux parce que on est quand même sur
le sport fait quand même beaucoup
d'argent partout dans le monde elle est
grand chelem c'est d'une machine à cash
non quand on est relativement des pays
mais au top niveau c1
je dirais que ça commence à rentrer dans
t'es tu commences à faire de l'argent
mais quand tu es censé quartier maison
t150 et moment de ta carrière se fait
pas vraiment d'argent arrive juste super
sourire un peu d'argent mais je vais pas
l'argent après 80 ans top 50 attaques 30
top 20 il a dû commencer directement à
sa définition de riches ou non mais pour
moi je commence à être à être rejetée
parce que tu commences à faire des
travaux prize money ton équipe de foot
quelque chose mais ce qui reste c'est
quand même ces crimes est largement
considéré donc appareils la disparité
est justement
hibon pis si les meilleurs au monde ça
m'a même 550m monde est quand même un
des meilleurs au monde ne pense pas la
différence entre à être multi
millionnaire ou à être juste
ces dates pilotes tous que ça
tout ce que ça implique tout l'effort
que sa demande et après ça c'est
quelques positions qui va faire cette
différence là c'est fou quand même moi
et puis si je suis pas un grand show
aussi ça joue à plusieurs mètres
quelques matchs dans l'année oui sur
toute une année c'est un niveau pee wee
et là il y en a un qui me disait souvent
mais quand j'ai vu que j'avais 14 ans
qu'ils aient le le niveau le livre ne
ment pas à la fin de la journée
concentre surtout au niveau de jeu
qu'elle soit perdre quelques matches
mais après si tu maintiens mon niveau ce
qui concentre à maintenir son niveau de
jeu mais au final sera pas mentir sur
sur la fin de l'année sur toute une
carrière
mais c'est sûr c'est que quand je vois
pas ce que certains supports qui joue à
l'international c'est quand c'est la
crise pour adultes et la natation c'est
déjà tout le monde tellement une masse
de gens qui font ça c'est tellement une
masse d'athlètes dans ses dix finales
qui dit qu'il y en a si peur qui gagnent
très bien leur vie qu'ils sont sondages
le prix du sucre en rejetant leur ok tu
dis c'est très bien mais c'est parce que
c'est ma différence et lyng je trouve
dans un même pays canada et j'ai dit
mettons mais si comme je peux le 500ème
jour là les salaires c'est très roots ou
est ce qui fait qu'ils en plus les
dépenses qu'il ya c'est ça rien à voir
avec avec ce combat ou quel sport
individuel à tout et tout et pays pour
lui toute sa carrière à roule tout ce
qui revient juste pour visiter mais
c'est vrai que nous la réalité fixité
des quatre centièmes
absolument et un déficit astronomique et
quatre centièmes de mieux de partir
c'est le 150e
il doit s'entraîner autant le but est
que tout est peut-être pas autant ou
avec la même ferveur mais doit mettre
sensiblement le même genre ah oui ou non
je te jure je peux garantir qu'ils ont
visités c'est juste qu'il pour une
raison ou une autre et par des choix sur
son son parcours chacun son histoire
mais un choix qui parce que nous on fait
on est circuit atp le territoire
petit circuit challenger jack locke
comme ça dit pas son nom le titre un peu
comme la létard en dessous qui est
circuit challenger joie qui veulent
seulement sur circuit challenger je peux
rentrer dans tes pattes et des
transferts a peur mais toute une
carrière sur ce que challenger se fera
pas beaucoup d'argent
d'ailleurs vraiment évolué dans le
circuit atp tour sur toute l'année
flic tous les grands chelems que vous
êtes et les grands chelems ayons des
bourses incroyable et je pense que deux
soprani donc aussi continuer à monter
c'est l'us open sont rendus cinquante ou
soixante mille américains premier tour
soit exposée au site
quand tu te sens comment ça allait
gagner ta vie parce que si tu fais les
cas le chien était assuré d'avoir le
comme un million deux cent mille deux
cent mille d'ios à la fin d'année
excellent aussi comment ça après tout
est frais c'est pas 2 samedi 13h à la
fin d'année mais c'est dans ce sens
commence à gagner ta vie très vite avant
ça c'est toi champ de gsk
est-ce que les olympiques est un
objectif pour toi c'est à temps plein
non c'est là que j'allais faire
complètement way complètement c'est sûr
que là je voyais sigée finance et son
21e puis jetée comme les olympiques
l'été prochain si belle si j'ai même
classement
arrivé au coach des olympiques et thomas
secret dedans savait pas comment ils ont
classé mais comment ça fonctionne
il ya un sélectionne un homme fixe par
pays comment ça fonctionne
un pouce sur parce que c'est mes
premiers puisse arrêter une famille je
seek exemple ça dépasse tout comme
combinant top 50
je pense qu'il ya un max os x peuvent
prendre part pays sûr c'est peut-être
trop 4 mais je sais pas je pense que tu
as tellement sûr parce qu'un exemple
tort parce qu'ils étaient des plastiques
sont réservés aux autres pays peu
importe au classement il ya comme des je
pourrais peut-être une place puis un
joueur qui venait de abadou ou des
autres pays qui sont mettant sa 50e 2
centièmes mais parce que c'est les
olympiques qui réservent des places pour
que les droits de tous les pays au passé
soit un enjeu des pays d'europe ou
d'amérique
j'ai aussi de la place pour les pays
d'asie des pays de l'afrique dans ce
disque mais je suis pas exactement sur
du nombre mais je sais que cette année
j'aurai j'aurais pu mettre dedans je
pense qu'il faut que ce soit ce soir
tome 3 to pay puis c'est quoi le c'est
quoi le la le rapport des olympiques
pour les athlètes sur le pro tour c'est
quoi ça en termes de valeur symbolique
qu'est ce que ça représentait ce que ce
que tu gagnes les olympiques puis c'est
mieux qu'un grand chelem est ce que
c'est comme grand chelem et on en terme
de prestige ou de prester joints ceux ci
je pensais juste en dessous des grands
chelems et ses personnels aussi
personnage au 6 mai mais comment je me
vois c'est que quand même les quatre
grands chelems reste un joueur au tennis
exemple avec ta carrière tu aies gagné
un ou deux grands chelems c'est pas
gagné une médaille c'est quand même
beaucoup plus prestigieux puis exemple
qui te passionne médaille de faire une
médaille à tilleur jamais gagné une
médaille d'or en simple les gays
médaille d'or en double mais j'aime bien
aimé naître en saint est ce que personne
en parle trop tôt mais je pense que
pour moi tu es lesquels grand chelem qui
après tout juste après tout les
olympiques et affronter les autres
tournois et inversement je pense que ce
qu'un coin ce qui est incroyable
on parle quand même de fédérer comme le
tennis beaucoup ont été blessés un peu
c'est malheureux mais mais j'étais
blessée énormément d'affilée s'accroche
là pour essayer de revenir mais serait
très difficile mais lui gagné 2,2 à epic
nadal a gagné sou de p g en 2008 ge
mais ça risque pour moi personnellement
ça serait presque au même niveau juste
en dessous des grands chelems et est ce
que tu es ce que tu joues encore en
double avec au moins beaucoup moins lui
il ya eu un partenaire justice la saison
avec un partenaire indien se passe
plutôt bien
ils jouent bien ensemble puis c'est lui
et à eagan plus que moi quitte à 20% la
part d'un mois sur le circuit moi je
serai peut-être un an après vraiment
sauver territoire donc
donc moi j'aime parce qu'en fait ça ils
prouvent au classement combiné pour
qu'elle vous dans un tournoi et lui a
listé jackson partenaires qui jouait
bien ensemble et comment je t'avais je
fais enfin entrer dans les classes par
et au tableau de double ou si je me suis
trouvé d'autre part annoncé que joue
avec une grosse priorité pour moi ici
c'est que ça demande beaucoup d'énergie
gsm comment ça j'ai un peu plus parce
que je pense que c'est bon pour mon jeu
épique c'est c'est ça développe un autre
aspect requis c'est bien mais ces
petites machines jeux tournois en simple
que chaque jour ou presque étant le
trader semaine la maison la coupe rogers
à montréal
j'ai joué le mardi mercredi et je devais
juste pour moi je jouais chaque jour si
je vous lance notre jeu du mardi au
dimanche et le samedi est rajouté du
double après celle des exemples mardi tu
joues et maintenant
à 11 ans à 14 ans je sois ou le fromage
2 et ici ça ajoute quand même beaucoup
d'énergie sur une scène ont sacré fait
beaucoup de matches en plus donc
j'essaie de choisir les tournois de
faire des fois le dos mais des fois je
ne fais pas là puisqu'il joie sont
presque forcé a choisi à se spécialiser
+102 brun way était vraiment les
spécialistes de deux de plus en plus
parce que l'exigence le niveau a
augmenté donc les joies qui se
spécialise vraiment uniquement deux tu
penses que tous les jours a commencé en
jouant simple c'est beaucoup plus
prestigieux mais après les choix se sont
spécialisés en double
le joueur canadien dernière nation qui a
gagné tous les tournois je les gens les
gens les gens de deux gains et où les
majeures en 2d gagner de serre est
piquant de loi 2000
ce n'est pas comment ces croyants la
coupe davis pour le canada donc celui-ci
spécialisé début de sa vingtaine
d'hommes qui étaient peintes 50e au
monde se sente y en a cinq ou six qui ce
qui est magnifique
donc il ya des gens qui se disent
beaucoup joueurs et c'est les adopter
les joies qui font un peu des deux mais
youtube une concentration un peu plus
saintes ou d'opter est-ce que c'est
difficile d'entretenir des relations
avec des gens qui sont pas en ton
entourage de tennis mettons avoir une
blonde à l'étape où est ce que tu es
dans ton parcours avoir tient une
partenaire avoir quelque chose qui
changera quelque chose qui faisait donc
j'en ai une journée une d'ailleurs ça
fait on se rencontre toile miami 2019 et
que ça fait 1-1 et quelques jours puis
et non ça se passe plutôt bien à leurs
cousines thibal tennis professionnel et
donc la chance que j'ai c'est 4 connaît
cabine le milieu qui est l effet
l'équitation effective le sport
professionnel la compétition sont pas
l'été équestre un cavalier professionnel
donc si connaît quand même donc c'est à
comprendre exemple que au stade où on
est rendu à nos propres vies t elle à
ses études sur l'équitation moi j'ai
matériels affectés on nomme cette
première concentration là qui après on
essaie de gérer notre temps notre
ensemble comment montpellier ça se passe
ça se passe très bien être qui est en
floride où elle et on se lave avec sa
famille c'est un peu courtes et
rustiques fallait que je revienne en
famille était comme elle a intégré dans
la famille en floride s attendait tous
mais la famille en belgique ou si ses
parents sont en belgique qui sait comme
compliquée c'est ce n'est pas serré
entre empêcher ça reste hélas mois salle
et je rentre à montréal mais non mais en
général je peux tenir les relations mais
il faut aussi que la personne avait
comprennent ce que tu dis je sache tous
les disciples et les écuries ce que ça
prend que ça peut vouloir dire qu'on
vous voit moins souvent mais si vous
croyez en votre coupe qui vous pensez qu
organe si ça vaut la peine ce qui est le
meilleur pour tout le monde mais c'est
toujours un moyen de s'arranger
ça me fascine - télé tu vois mettons un
lebron james qui clairement peu importe
peu importe si l'avouerait ouvertement
ou non c'est sûr que le basket ball
c'est sa priorité numéro un
même si probablement que healy adore sa
famille adore sa femme il aime fort il
aime ses enfants
c'est sûr que pour atteindre ce niveau
là lui le basketball est la priorité
numéro un est une
c'est sûr que quand c'est sûr que sa
femme est au courant de ces gars là même
blonde depuis vraiment longtemps dans
moby c'est sûr que l cancalais embarquer
là dedans a dit acdi consciemment ou non
que allait à être deuxièmes derrière
sûreté derrière cette espèce de passion
le team fake j'ai toujours trouvé ça
super fasse la même chose avec la femme
de federer le team et on est tout le
temps là qui élève les enfants qui le
suit partout tu sais c'est comme tout
est axé vers la carrière de la question
c'est comment on fait chuter la famille
dans la carrière c'est pas le contraire
que cette question-là l'espère je
l'espère pas non mais je comprends que
ces gars là aussi c'est quelque chose
qui assure que je pense que aussi alors
haut niveau c'est facile facile pour la
rampe d'accès au site
mais ça reste qu' il ya beaucoup à
pointer les binchois obscures c'est
peut-être la forme si elle ses projets
personnels 6 à l'autre sens et c'est là
aussi si elle aussi sa carrière mais si
elle doit on le voit c'est valable pour
un homme comme pour une fête après le
léger donner l'exemple de ses douleurs
ça pourrait très bien être le cas le
tome 2 sharapova là pendant un bon outil
la championne ne sort que alex morgan
c'est son job prépa mais cerignola i am
still
mais quand un quelconque doigt comme
sacrifiés pour que ça chrtr pour l'autre
pour passer que son épouse est enfermé
après si c'est la famille une autre vie
peut-être pas mathieu année je priorise
la famille je me dis mon le jour d'une
famille baud et la ta carrière mais ça
reste la famille ça reste notre priorité
qui paie pas au même niveau mais aussi
prêté ce cocon mois égale ou différentes
mais en gérant du penseur sites
différents
c'est différent mais pour moi c'est
quelque chose que je sais que je vais
refaire un jour mais je pense que c'est
toujours oui de savons que ce sont des
restos haut niveau ne peux pas te
permettre de disperser de perdre la
concentration sûreté intérieure mais
rien n'empêche pas l'autre à la fin de
ces différents il faut juste des
structures et des choses bien s'adapter
mais pour moi je
confiant empêche pas la route et ses
courbes in2pay le bon exemple de dire
que débite cartes voient comme une tête
ses enfants sa femme s'était quand même
je vois que j'ai excellé comme sportif
comme jour le basket-ball aussi que le
père de famille donc ceci dit c'est un
très bel exemple de dire est que les
deux sont compatibles et je pense que
moi en fait en fait pour pour prendre
précisément son exemple à lui j'ai
l'impression qu'il est devenu un bon
père de famille quand sa carrière était
finie
aussi je pense que je pense que tout le
monde était tout le monde m'apparaissait
comme étant conscient de ce que c'est
que ça allait devenir le corps une fois
que la carrière allait à l'heure je
pense qu'il en est des joueurs qui ont
des enfants durant leur carrière c'est
plus compliqué c'est après parce que
c'est vraiment un gros chrono j'ai tjs
que les sports professionnels pour ce
n'est pas pour rien que physiquement
mais aussi mentalement dans le
relationnel utilise pour ce que c'est
plutôt des jeunes de 20 ans célibataire
mais ça reste que tu peux quand même
trouver des façons de concilier mais ça
dépend du niveau c'est moi j'ai mon
coach caluire avril j'en ai fait j'en ai
deux je m'inquiétais 60e mieux ils ont
été 2 centièmes au monde et où est ce
que c'est
ils sont divers avec l'argent je fais si
je vais avoir une famille je veux pas
être partie toute l'année en tournoi
quand en face au tas maison bay ont dû
faire un choix qui doit écouter le choix
sera que je mets fin à ma carrière je me
concentre plus sur d'autres projets qui
sur notre année ces choix là dans une
vie afin de conseiller les deux encore
mieux merci merci vraiment apprécié une
superbe la conversation
lorsqu'on sait poursuit aussi tout
annulés jusqu'à au moins juillet je
pense
ouais c'est ça je suis et puis après son
agression vers eux mais sinon
c'est quoi la prochaine étape maintenant
à l'automne ce qui est non mais roland
garros à paris j'étais en mai mais ils
ont rapporté en septembre c'est un peu
bizarre parce que comme l'us open en
septembre juste après roland garros
mais là aussi deux le second ne va pas
se tenir pétrole à la hausse pour hasni
si le pic était sans doute mais un
moment heureux mais vraiment je suis une
pro plus de nouvelles de personne
d'autre
c'est fou ce qui s'est passé je disais
qu'est wimbledon annulé c'est pas de riz
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
à ce niveau leur portée c'est ce qui est
bon de prendre une claque mais laisse
les mains sportif tout ce qui est
l'essentiel en fait moi ils prennent une
sérieuse claque c'est à dire mais c'est
parce que ça me garder
pas trop merci parce que une partie que
j'aime aussi de ce que je fais c'est
partagé qui permet une très bonne
conversation
j'adore partager l'affiché où city un
mot sur des sites commencent à se lasser
comme si je serai leçons de ce que vous
avez dit dans votre propre milieu puis
c'est ça qui touche autant c'est
vraiment comment arrêter convaincre
merci tf1 qu'il fait très bien pauvre et
partager ta passion puis ton expérience
continue achieve com est un vrai fan
tout le succès du mur